Eyes are incredible and complex creations.
To see, light is focused by the cornea, passes
through a clear lens and is encoded by the
retina, which sends electrical impulses to
the brain.
But if you have a cataract, proteins on the
lens start to cloud together, creating blurry
vision.
For over 20 million people, this is how they
see the world.
Cataracts are the leading cause of blindness
globally.
“Blindness affects your life expectancy.
You become a hangout, you become an appendage
for the family.
And then you become an economic burden.”
But thanks to a revolutionary surgical method,
sight can be restored in just under five minutes.
The small incision surgery is generally a
very cost effective, and simple manual technique
to remove cataract and still give the patient
comparable results.
For over 20 years, Dr. Sanduk Ruit pioneered
a surgical method and his team of doctors
have performed over 600,000 surgeries.
In just five minutes, surgeons make a tiny
incision in the eye, remove the cataract and
insert an artificial lens.
Dr. Ruit’s goal is to rid the world of treatable
blindness with this quick and affordable method,
and today he’s doing just that.
Tucked away in the mountains of Nepal, crowds
of prospective patients are waiting their
turn for an eye exam.
They’ve traveled long distances and across
challenging terrain to the Tilganga Institute
of Ophthalmology, a nonprofit clinical eye
facility founded by Dr. Ruit.
“Every time we see a bigger line we tend
to increase the stations inside, and there
are more doctors, more staff who are working
now.”
Born in Nepal, Dr. Ruit has dedicated his
life’s work to bringing cost-effective,
hospital grade care to the world’s poorest
regions.
“It's a beautiful moment.
Every moment when the patches come off, when
you see the smile on the patient's face, it's
always very nice, it's this ticklish feeling.
It charges your battery and makes you work
harder.”
Dr. Ruit and his team have established mobile
surgery camps in North Korea, China, Bhutan,
and Ethiopia, training local medical professionals
and treating as many patients as possible.
“Tilganga has been a front-runner in delivering
this high quality surgery at places where
there are no health facilities.”
Dr. Ruit’s game changing surgical method
comes down to a small incision and an affordable
intraocular lens.
The lenses are manufactured in a state of
the art fabrication lab, and they cost just
$4 each.
These lenses typically cost $100 in the developed
world.
“These are highly special plastic materials
that you put and have no reaction in the eye
at all.”
The lab produces about 350,000 lenses annually
and sells them to over 60 countries.
“In West, most of the medical bills are
very expensive, and partly because the state
and the people can pay for it.
And here, we have to make it cost effective
because people can't pay for it.”
Inside the hospital, Dr. Ruit and his team
are preparing for the day’s surgeries.
“The whole idea of the small incision surgery
is to make the wound self-sealing, and the
idea of making a wound self-sealing is to
have an external opening and an internal opening
at two different planes.
You go and make a tunnel and have internal
opening in another place, make an opening
into the cataract.
Once the cataract has come out, it's more
like a boiled egg.
The yellow of the egg is the nucleus, which
you take out now, and then you go in and remove
the rest of the white of the egg.
And you have the shell of the egg on the back,
which you have to intentionally keep intact.
And on the shell of the egg, you put the intraocular
lens.
The intraocular lense will allow you to focus
and not, not leave you long-sighted.
There are many instances where it changes
the life of the person.
The things that we have done here in Nepal,
especially in Tilganga, which has caused some
revolution in public health of ophthalmology.
Cataract surgeries, and of that, probably
15 million wouldn't have been able to get
this surgery done if an organization like
us hadn't done this kind of homework.
So now they can get it done so the impact
you can see.
They can have this kind of surgery, cost effectively,
the number of surgeries can go up.
So I think that, it has a great public health
impact.”